auf der suche nach unterstützern
verteidigungsministerin kramp
karrenbauer wirbt bei der nato für ihre
idee einer internationalen
sicherheitstruppe in nordsyrien neue
details nach den leichenfunden in einem
lkw die in großbritannien entdeckten 39
toten stammen aus china
und letzte amtshandlung von mister
nullzins mario draghi der scheidende
präsident der europäischen zentralbank
lässt den leitzins bei 0%
die nachrichten nicht dass leute mit
christian sievers in allen danke für ihr
interesse an uns das schon mal vorweg
sport habe auch in der sendung mit
kristin otto nachher und
fußball-champions-league guten abend wir
beginnen mit der großen frage findet die
deutsche verteidigungsministerin
unterstützer für ihren vorschlag in
nordsyrien mit einer internationalen
truppe eine sicherheitszone einzurichten
und zu überwachen
annegret kramp karrenbauer trifft heute
ihre nato amtskollegen in brüssel
und will sie von ihrer initiative
überzeugen dazu genüge kurz vor der
debatte über die lage in syrien schenkt
der generalsekretär der deutschen
verteidigungsministerin einen
achtungserfolg
ohne ebase alle business partner
unterstützen die anstrengungen für eine
internationale politische lösung und der
deutsche vorschlag ist ein element davon
schon am morgen im glanz eines brüsseler
ballsaals sei es für einen moment so aus
als habe der vorschlag aus berlin
selbst beim mächtigsten nato partner
eine chance er habee nicht gelesen sagt
der us-verteidigungsminister aber ich
denke das ist gut denn wir bitten unsere
europäischen partner seit einer ganzen
weile darum also unterstütze ich das
dann schiebt er nach
ich unterstütze das politisch wir wollen
keine bodentruppen stellen sätze die die
nato kennt von deutschen
verteidigungsminister die neue probt den
rollentausch vom gespräch mit dem
türkischen minister über ihren vorschlag
berichtet sie dass es sich sehr offen
gezeigt hat im bilateralen gespräch dass
dies auch unter einbeziehung der
internationalen gemeinschaft erfolgen
könnte dass die türkei dazu zu
gesprächen auch bereit ist als wäre es
vergessen das wort von der türkischen
annexion syrischer gebiete ausgesprochen
gestern beim truppenbesuch ihre wortwahl
wird in brüssel nicht diskutiert ihr
vorschlag am rande schon insofern ist
der diskussionsprozess angestoßen das
wird noch ein langer prozess ein
schwieriger weg aber die ersten schritte
die ersten gespräche heute waren sehr
ermutigend
die nato als ganze fühlt sich dabei
nicht angesprochen
vielleicht dabei einzelne bündnispartner
das klingt alles noch so ein bisschen
verhalten stefan leifert ist unser mann
in brüssel stefan guten abend man könnte
annehmen die deutsche
verteidigungsministerium müsste
eigentlich heute kräftig unterstützung
bekommen für ihren vorschlag weil sie
sonst wenig chancen hat ihn umzusetzen
gab es denn diesen rückenwind heute nein
das ist heute nicht der tag an dem der
vorschlag von annegret kramp karrenbauer
auf internationaler ebene jetzt grosse
rat angenommen hätte es gab keinen
einzigen bündnispartner der sich heute
demonstrativ und öffentlich hinter die
vorschläge aus berlin gestellt hat dafür
gibt es zwei gründe der eine grund ist
dass sich viele nato-mitglieder einfach
schlecht und zu spät über den vorschlag
aus deutschland informiert fühlen und
auch im laufe der sitzung die jetzt hier
gerade zu ende gegangen ist muss vieles
noch sehr im nebulösen und wagen
geblieben sein
andere wiederum und das ist der zweite
grund finden dass die nato auch gar
nicht der richtige ort ist um diesen
vorstoß zu diskutieren selbst der
nato-generalsekretär hat heute gesagt
dass das eigentlich eine sache sei
die bei den vereinten nationen viel
besser aufgehoben wäre
das positivste was heute zu hören war
war das ist doch gut sein dass jetzt
endlich mal ein europäischer vorschlag
in sachen syrien auf dem tisch liegt
aber das ist so ziemlich das schwächste
lob was man im diplomaten sprich
erteilen kann sehr verhalten das echo
also in brüssel bei der nato stefan
leifert vielen dank und wir bleiben noch
im moment beim thema und gucken jetzt
auf die lage aktuell in der krisenregion
also die grenze von syrien zur türkei so
sieht sie aus die so genannte
sicherheitszone beschlossen von der
türkei und russland das ziel
syrische flüchtlinge aus der türkei
hierher umsiedeln und kämpfer der
kurdischen milizen von der grenze
zurückdrängen vor den kämpfen sind
bereits mehr als 170.000 menschen vor
allem kurden geflohen glück war port mit
mehr russische militär polizei rückte
heute wie hier in kamishli in die
syrischen orten entlang der türkischen
grenze vor das verteidigungsministerium
in moskau bestätigte bewaffnete
kurdische einheiten zögen sich gemäss
der vereinbarung von sochi aus dem 30
kilometer grenzstreifen zurück
in einem telefonat mit dem russischen
verteidigungsminister schoigu erklärte
der kurdische kommandeur ab die es seien
noch einige punkte zu klären
aber er dankte moskau dass russland der
bevölkerung weiteren krieg erspart habe
staatspräsident erdogan widersprach
unterdessen den aussagen von
us-präsident trump die militäraktion sei
beendet
wenn die terror-organisation unser land
von diesen regionen aus weiterhin
belästigt dann werden wir unseren plan
der offensive weiterhin durchführen
im türkischen grenzort so roach sind sie
froh dass die waffen schweigen
100.000 menschen leben hier mehrheitlich
kurden und weitere 40.000 flüchtlinge
die geplante umsiedlung von flüchtlingen
nach syrien sehen sie skeptisch es gibt
ja auch viele flüchtlinge die nicht
zurück wollen weil sie sich hier ein
neues leben aufgebaut haben die
ortsansässigen möchten allerdings dass
die syrer zurückgehen die furcht nicht
nur der bürgermeisterin ist das bei der
rückführung die ethnische
zusammensetzung jenseits der grenze
gewaltsam verändert wird und jetzt das
große thema exit der britische
premierminister boris johnson hat ein
weiteres mal neuwahlen gefordert und
zwar für den 12 dezember
da der ungeordnete praxis ja vom tisch
sei erwarte er dass diesmal auch die
labour-partei dem zustimme sagte johnson
in einem interview
schon am montag soll über neuwahlen
entschieden werden
boris johnson braucht eine
zweidrittelmehrheit ein grausiger fund
gestern in der nähe von london in einem
lkw anhänger liegen 39 leichen die
ermittler sagen heute es handelt sich um
31 männer und acht frauen aus china nach
einschätzung der belgischen
staatsanwaltschaft ist der container vor
zwei tagen in der hafenstadt zeebrügge
angekommen
wenige stunden später wurde er über die
nordsee ins englische per flieht
verschifft mehr von andreas stamm
die vorerst letzte fahrt eines lasters
indessen kühlcontainer 39 menschen
starben 31 männer acht frauen aus china
die identität jedes einzelnen opfers
festzustellen könnte wochen dauern so
die polizei er flieht hier war der
anhänger per fähre aus dem belgischen
zeebrügge angekommen in der kleinstadt
ein offenes geheimnis in den containern
werden auch menschen geschmuggelt nicht
jeder der darüber spricht will erkannt
werden
ich habe kürzlich sechs menschen gesehen
die aus einem anhänger geklettert sind
genau da wo das jetzt passiert ist jeder
hier in der gegend hat so etwas schon
erlebt und niemand interessiert sich
dafür
da kommen auf uns taxifahrer zu keiner
spricht englisch sie geben die ein handy
und jemand am anderen ende sagte ihr
gehören sie gefahren werden sollen
das problem die gefahren sind bekannt
spätestens seit im juni 2000 58 chinesen
ebenfalls in einem cluster umkamen
entdeckt wurden die leichen im hafen von
dover die handynummern der kontaktperson
in england auf die kleidung geschrieben
auch damals kam der anhänger aus dem
belgischen zeebrügge und 4000 container
werden hier täglich verschifft erst
kürzlich wurden neueste scanner im kampf
gegen menschenschmuggel installiert
dürften die opfer schon vor der ankunft
in england im anhänger gewesen sein
sie müssten jedes fahrzeug das in
zeebrügge verladen wird kontrollieren
dafür fehlen noch immer die
möglichkeiten möglichkeiten um den tod
von menschen zu verhindern
zu verhindern dass ein kondolenzbuch
ausgelegt werden muss
für diesmal 39 menschen zurück nach
deutschland der vertrag für eine rot
schwarz grüne koalition in brandenburg
steht knapp acht wochen nach der wahl
hat sich die verhandlungsrunde von spd
cdu und grünen auf ihr
regierungsprogramm geeinigt details sagt
spd-ministerpräsident dietmar woidke
soll es morgen geben jetzt ein
gerichtsurteil und die frage dürfen zwei
männer weiter als lehrer arbeiten bei
denen kinderpornografische bilder und
filme gefunden wurden
das bundesverwaltungsgericht entschied
heute nein auch kann ihnen der status
als beamter entzogen werden
die vorinstanz
hat das noch anders gesehen die fälle
liegen also etwas komplizierter sarah
tacke sie haben sich den missbrauch von
kindern angesehen zu hause an ihrem
privaten computer zwei lehrer aus berlin
das steht fest
denn sie sind dafür rechtskräftig
verurteilt worden mussten jeweils rund
4000 euro strafe zahlen
milde strafen also die die richter damit
begründet hatten die lehrer hätten nicht
so viele und nicht so schlimme
missbrauchs filme und fotos gehabt für
die senatsverwaltung berlin ist aber
klar diese lehrer sollen nie wieder vor
schülern stehen nach den uns
vorliegenden informationen sehen wir uns
veranlasst die vertrauensgrundlage als
dauerhaft beschädigt anzusehen und
plädieren auf eine entfernung aus dem
beamtenverhältnis
um das zu erreichen ist das land berlin
bis vor das bundesverwaltungsgericht
gezogen
denn die gerichte zuvor gaben den
lehrern recht heute nun die wende
die richter am bundesverwaltungsgericht
stellen neue verschärfte grundsätze auf
es hat entschieden dass auch geringe
mengen dieses materials und aller regel
dazu führt dass der betroffene lehrer
aus dem dienst zu entfernen ist wieder
die betroffenen lehrer noch ihre anwälte
wollten sich zu der entscheidung äußern
das urteil aber verändert die rechtslage
für viele damit korrigiert das
bundesverwaltungsgericht seine bisherige
rechtsprechung und das hat sowohl
grundsätzlich als auch weitreichende
bedeutung für jeden der mit kindern
arbeitet dann geht es gilt wer sich den
missbrauch von kindern ansieht muss
nicht nur mit strafrechtlichen sondern
auch mit den härtesten beruflichen
konsequenzen rechnen
diese verschärfte rechtsprechung
begrüßte die lehrergewerkschaft gew
heute gegenüber dem zdf
der ard droht eine strafzahlung in höhe
von 396 1000 euro das ist das dreifache
einer spende aus der schweiz die die
bundestagsverwaltung nachprüfung für
illegal hält sie will deshalb das
strafgeld verhängen
die afg soll sich nun zur schweiz spende
äußern sowie zu einer weiteren aus den
niederlanden die partei behält sich
rechtsmittel vor
etwa 90.000 auszubildende können ab
januar mit mehr geld rechnen
der bundestag hat eine mindestlohn von
515 euro pro monat im ersten lehrjahr
beschlossen
er ist teil einer reform des
berufsbildungsgesetzes das den azubis
auch freie tage vor prüfungen zum lernen
garantiert gewerkschaften grüne und
linke begrüßten die reform halten dem
mindestlohn allerdings für zu niedrig
und jetzt das ende einer ära zum letzten
mal leitet mario draghi heute die
ratssitzung der europäischen zentralbank
november 2011 mitten in der europäischen
finanzkrise wird der italiener präsident
der ezb und beruhigt mit nur drei worten
die lage
whatever it takes er machte damit
deutlich dass die ezb alles unternehmen
werde um den euro zu schützen
dazu gehören umstrittene anleihekäufe
und eine drastische politik der
niedrigen zinsen wenige tage im amt
senkt draghi den leitzins seit 2016
liegt er bei null prozent
peter wagener zieht bilanz entspannt und
locker wie selten mario draghi bei
seiner letzten pressekonferenz überhaupt
deutlich seine mahnung an die
regierungen endlich ihre
wirtschaftspolitischen aufgaben zu
erledigen
die strukturpolitik in der eurozone muss
substanziell stärker werden um die
produktivität und das wachstum zu
steigern
rückblick die euro-krise auf dem
höhepunkt griechenland droht der
staatsbankrott irland spanien portugal
und italien kommen ins schlingern die
regierungen zögern da sprich trage die
worte die die wende einleiten
die ezb wird alles tun um den euro zu
bewahren
das versprechen war letztlich notwendig
um den euro zu sichern und damit auch
dass der euro seine erste wirklich große
feuerprobe bestanden hat die geldpolitik
des ezb-rats unter draghi umstritten
aber erfolgreich die zentralbank kauft
staatsanleihen senkt die leitzinsen bis
auf null flutet die wirtschaft
geld gut für verbraucher schlecht für
sparer in draghis zeit keine inflation
aber die deutschen haushalte verlieren
335 milliarden euro an zinsen hat die dz
bank errechnet
kg und die ezb haben der aufgaben
übernommen die eigentlich die politik
die regierungen übernehmen müssten darf
nicht zur wirtschaftsregierung der euro
zone werden denn dafür braucht man ein
demokratisches mandat mario draghi hat
euro geschichte geschrieben aber seine
geldpolitik hat er den deutschen nicht
immer überzeugend erklären können
am ende kann es schnell gehen bei
unbezahlter rechnungen und der mahnung
den strom abzustellen kann es schon vier
wochen später dunkel und kalt werden
2018 gab es stromsperren in fast 300.000
haushalten
das steht in einer antwort der
bundesregierung auf eine anfrage der
grünen die dem zdf vorliegt die grünen
bringen deshalb morgen einen
gesetzesantrag ein sie wollen eine
stromkosten pauschale bei der
grundsicherung zu einem düsteren kapitel
in der geschichte spaniens jetzt dass
die spanier wieder neu umtreibt
francisco franco faschistischer diktator
über vier jahrzehnte hinweg
einer der mit hitler gemeinsame sache
machte einer der foltern und morden ließ
19 75 starb franco doch die verehrung
für den despoten lebt fort zumindest bei
einigen seine grabstätte eine
pilgerstätte auch um das zu stoppen
wurde franco heute umgebettet thomas
walde berichtet es gab keine
militärischen ehren und auch keine
spanische flagge auf dem sarg als
familienmitglieder den leichnam des
diktators franco aus dem mausoleum
trugen die regierung hatte die
exhumierung so durchgesetzt
die öffentliche verherrlichung des
diktators war mehr als ein anachronismus
oder eine anomalie sie war ein
schwerwiegender merkel für die spanische
demokratie francisco franco hatte 1936
gegen die regierung geputscht
es folgte ein fast dreijähriger
bürgerkrieg den die franquisten gewonnen
hunderttausende gegner wurden ermordet
zu lebzeiten ließ sich franco von
zwangsarbeitern ein mausoleum bauen
das seither zur wallfahrtsstätte für
ewiggestrige wurde
einige kamen auch heute wen stört es
denn dass er hier ist doch nur die roten
uns nicht welche notwendigkeit gibt es
dann wirklich jemanden nach 40 jahren
aus dem grab zu holen
doch die umbettung ist symbolisch
bedeutsam vor allem für die angehörigen
der opfer des diktators fausto kanal es
war zwei jahre alt als sein vater
erschossen wurde weil er in einer
gewerkschaft war überreste des diktators
an so einem privilegierten platz geehrt
in einem mausoleum dass er zu seinem
glanz und seiner größe errichten ließ
wir finden es gut dass sie ihn da
rausholen
es war ein tag an dem in spanien die
erinnerung an die toten auf lebte und
bei den angehörigen der opfer die
hoffnung dass sie den frank ismus
nunmehr hinter sich lassen können
und damit sind wir in dieser sendung
beim sport christines wirst du heute
königsklasse hängende köpfe nach einer
schwachen vorstellung borussia dortmund
kassiert bei inter mailand 1 0 2 und
rutscht auf tabellenplatz drei ab ein
herber rückschlag im kampf richtung
achtelfinale es brodelt rund um
schwarz-gelb trainer lucien favre steht
ob der leistung seiner mannschaft in der
kritik nur zwei siege aus den letzten
sieben spielen sportdirektor zorc sagt
er wolle keine trainerdiskussion führen
dortmund hat chancen aber nicht allzu
viele wirkt uninspiriert und
streckenweise harmlos dass marco reus
und paco alcácer fehlen ist an allen
ecken und enden spürbar hat so der
letzte punch gefehlt dagegen verhalten
ja auch das ist richtig internet auch
noch aggressive spielweise an den tag
gelegt oder sehr diszipliniert wollen
wir sie aber auch erwartet und inter
schafft in der ersten halbzeit die
führung weil nico schulz nicht aufpasst
und für eine abseitsposition einen
schritt zu weit hinten steht martina es
trifft bei der ersten chance von inter
in diesem spiel
eine minute vor schluss der
kontertreffer von candreva der bvb
verliert 0 2 am wochenende muss gegen
schalke einiges besser werden weitaus
besser die stimmung bei rb leipzig 2 2 1
gegen russlands meister zenit st
petersburg tabellenführung in der gruppe
c große erleichterung clever erkämpft
nicht nur trainer nagelsmann mit
geradezu hemmungsloser verzückung eine
zielstrebige leistung filigrane tore und
das ende der flaute von zuvor vier
pflichtspielen ohne sieg
wir waren nie nein krise sondern wir
wussten schnell was wir machen müssen um
wieder erfolg zu haben und ich finde da
haben wir heute gezeigt vor allem in der
zweiten halbzeit nach nun zu 1 rückstand
da schießt conrad lay mal den ausgleich
das wunderschöne siegtor zum 2 1 geht
auf das konto von marcel sabitzer zwei
siege in drei spielen da zeichnet sich
schon das achtelfinale am horizont ab
jetzt gehen wir für die nächsten spiele
und ich glaube dass ich eine super
ausgangsposition für die letzten drei
spiele dank zweier präzisionsschützen
aus österreich neue chance samstag in
freiburg
ich habe noch einen kleinen vorab blick
aufs wetter im norden soll es windig
werden im süden bleibt es bei hochnebel
und sonnenschein viel mehr dazu gleich
von gunther tiersch und der vorab blick
aufs heute journal mit kollegen claus
kleber 21.45 und ganz frischen zahlen
vom politbarometer vor der wahl in
thüringen
danke für heute gerne bis morgen in
allen ein angenehmer abend
[Musik]
genome liebe zuschauer ist kommt wieder
mehr bewegung in unser wetter derzeit
liegt regen ein regengebiet über der
nordsee
das zieht nach norddeutschland rein aber
schwächt sich weitgehend ab was ist mit
bringt ist aber vor allen dingen morgen
dieser kräftige zum teil stürmischer
südwestwind in süddeutschland steigt der
luftdruck da würde es eher ruhig weiter
gehen heute nacht allerdings auch mit
etwas regen an den alpen auf der
schwäbischen alb und auch an der nordsee
gibt es dann erste regenschauer
sonst wird es teilweise klar es bilden
sich ein paar nebelfelder aber in
norddeutschland spielt das keine rolle
da haben wir auf jeden fall einen
wechsel von sonne und wolken nur in
schleswig holstein und einer nordsee
sind die wolken dichter ab und zu gibt
es kleine regenschauer bei diesem
stürmischem südwestwind in der mitte und
im süden ist da wesentlich schwächer
dafür sind die wolken der hochnebel
dichter und nachmittags kann er hier und
da doch ein paar lücken bekommen der
regen an den alpen lässt nachmittags
auch nach und haben freundlichsten wird
es im südwesten auf der schwäbischen alb
und im schwarzwald erscheint dann meist
die sonne und das wird auch im süden und
osten am wärmsten da sind es dann 19
oder sogar 20 grad sonst im norden und
westen 14 bis 17 grad die aussichten
bringen uns stürmisches wetter am
samstag in norddeutschland erste schauer
dann auch weitere schauer am sonntag und
es wird schon kühler
am montag haben wir nur noch 8 bis 14
grad
ich wünschen noch einen schönen abend
und machen sie es gut